Hello. This is 6 Minute
English from BBC
Learning English.
I'm Neil and I'm Phil.
Oh, what's that awful noise
Phil?
Sorry, Neil. I was biting my nails.
I know it's a bad
habit.
Urgh! It sounds terrible.
Sorry Neil. Actually.
It's not only you who finds
certain sounds irritating, unpleasant
or even unbearable.
Whether it's someone biting
their nails,
rustling a crisp bag or
scraping a knife on a dinner plate,
some everyday sounds have the power
to make us angry or upset
There's even a name for it:
'misophonia'
also known as sound rage
and it's more common than you might
think, according to some estimates
one person in five is
affected emotionally by the coughing,
slurping, sneezing and
snorting sounds made by the people
around them.
In this programme,
we'll be finding out more about the
medical condition 'misophonia'.
And as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first,
I have a question for you, Phil.
According to a recent survey
by the American journal,
Medical News,
which of the following did their
readers find the most unpleasant sound?
Is it a) bicycle brakes
squeaking, b) nails scraping
a blackboard or c) a baby crying.
Hmmm.... I'll guess it was
squeaky bicycle brakes.
I really hate that!
OK, Phil. We'll find out the answer
later in the programme.
For people suffering
from misophonia
the specific sounds which cause
them to become emotionally upset,
also known
as 'triggers' often involve food
and eating. Just sitting down
for dinner with their family
can feel like torture.
Olana Tansley-Hancock is
a British clinical researcher who
also suffers from misophonia.
Here she explains some
of her triggers to BBC
World Service Programme 'The Food
chain':
It's just any kind
of inescapable, repetitive noise
will potentially cause a misophonic-type
response in me, that fight-or-flight.
And, yeah,
it's that immediate, uncontrollable
reaction that you get to the sound
that is the most hard to explain
and unusual,
I think because I don't think
in modern day
you don't get many instances where
you get a fight-or-flight response.
It's not like we're frequently chased
down by wild animals and
then to feel those
from pretty innocuous everyday sounds
is the thing that takes its toll.
Certain sounds trigger a fight-or-flight
response in Olana. 'Fight-or-flight' refers
to the way the human body responds
to stressful or dangerous situations,
either by physically running away
or staying to deal with the threat.
Normally, these would be
life-threatening dangers,
things like a fire
or an attacking wild animal.
But for misophonia
sufferers even 'innocuous'
or completely harmless
sounds create problems.
That's right. Olana,
for example, gets disturbed by
helicopters flying in the sky and
the fact that other people don't seem
too bothered also takes its toll -
a phrase meaning
'causes suffering or pain'.
So, what does it feel like to actually
experience this kind of stress
in everyday life?
Here's Olana again,
explaining her feelings
to Ruth Alexander,
presenter of BBC
World Service Programme,
'The Food Chain'.
It's not the same feeling,
but it's the same response
in terms of the immediacy
and an inability to control it
as when someone tells you that
someone close to you has passed away
that feeling of utter sudden reaction.
You can't control it,
and then it lingers
and carries on for you
that immediate emotional
response.
Almost like
a shock to the system.
Yeah.
Olana describes her misophonia,
as an uncontrollable and sudden
emotional reaction as if finding out
that a loved one has passed away.
'Passed away' is a polite,
euphemistic way of saying 'died'.
She also describes it as a 'shock to the
system' - a sudden and unpleasant change.
Fortunately,
misophonia sufferers have developed
some tricks to help. Playing background
music can disguise the sound
of people sipping
and slurping their food and clearly,
honestly, explaining
what the condition is, also helps
people sympathise and understand. But
But of course,
some sounds simply are disturbing -
for example, you biting your nails, Phil.
OK, I said I was sorry.
Maybe it's time to reveal the answer
to your question
Neil, before you get more upset.
You asked me which sound was voted
the most irritating for readers
of the journal,
Medical News.
Right. And you guessed
it was bicycle brakes squeaking,
which was the wrong answer
I'm afraid, Phil.
In fact, nails scraping a blackboard
was voted the most distressing noise
and I completely agree.
Right, let's recap the vocabulary.
we have learned from this programme
on misophonia,
starting with 'trigger' -
something that causes people to feel
emotional distress or fear.
'Fight-or-flight' refers
to the natural human response
to a threatening situation
of either running away
was staying to face the danger.
The adjective
'innocuous' means completely harmless.
If something 'takes its toll',
it causes suffering, damage or death.
'Passed away' is a polite way
of saying 'died'.
And finally, the phrase a 'shock
to the system' means a sudden
and unpleasant change. Once again
our six minutes are up.
Join us again next time
for more trending topics
and useful vocabulary, here
at 6 Minute English.
Goodbye for now. Goodbye.